live on your channel alright you see me
I see you I check myself here good
Hans Thank You Man thank you as always
you are rocks do you guys are rock stars
you really I thank you so much your help
you're not allowed into my country for
donations
that's okay Andrew you know it's it's
just good to have you here anyway so hey
Peter Q it's good to see you
greetings Florida neighbor who nee
neighbor Rooney oh okay yes oh so you're
also in Central Florida I take it well
we should have some kind of hangout
Brian is muted too he should be okay
yeah I think you guys hear him now all
right
hey Dan hope things are good up in
Canada galaxia
John sup full atom synergy all of you
guys welcome it's good to have you back
we are gonna get started in just a
moment Tom Tom Garcia's like hey Tony
you must be a neighbor because I see the
same pop-up ads on your computer screen
as I get in st. Augustine to Daytona
Beach area that's exactly right I'm in
the Daytona Beach area so it's sad that
you're seeing my pop-up ads because I
ended up sharing my screen all the time
and I don't have an ad blocker so yeah
alright okay let's get started so we're
think we're finally there Bryan Keating
is with us you have been interviewing
Eric Weinstein and we talked about him a
little bit in part one we don't really
have a clip to highlight this video but
we don't need one because the link by
the way to the full part two of his
video and at least on the deep astronomy
channel is in the description box it's
video so you can watch it after we're
done introducing it to you don't go now
just wait until dinner right so Bryan
for people who are new here tell people
first of all what your podcast is all
about second of all what the second part
of this interview was that you did with
Eric so I do the into the impossible
podcast which is a production of the
arthur c-- clark center for human
imagination i have had on tremendously
important intellectuals thinkers and
people that are so-called influencers
and I'm trying to learn these tactics
and tricks that they use in order to
provide content that my audience enjoys
and a couple months ago I reached out to
an old friend hadn't been in great
contact with simply because every time I
invited him to come to San Diego I never
got a reply to accept the invitation but
now that's mine and and by the way it's
Weinstein not Weinstein and the Seinfeld
episode about that but the way to
remember you know the easiest way to
remember no so he's interested in
overthrowing Einstein oh well stated
Einstein and Einstein okay and so that's
the easiest way to know you're not hard
apologies apologies to Eric Weinstein
yes exactly so he might be listening
I've been in touch with him the last
couple of days and we're trying to
produce basically a cage match and I'm
interested to know if you guys and
Tony's channel on my channel how would
you like to see battle royale between
sean carroll eric weinstein stephen
wolfram maybe throw ed Witten into the
mix in all seriousness we're thinking
about doing some kind of a production
maybe a webinar I mean no one has agreed
to do this but this is just kind of our
idea in partnership with some other
physicists on YouTube and I don't know
if you know who will say yes but I think
you know the number one complaint that I
get is oh well why isn't Eric published
his results and why are you having a
mock again he has a fundamental
antipathy towards the current state of
academia
now you may agree with that you may
vehemently disagree with that and
hopefully we'll talk a little bit about
that the subtitle of today's astro
bookshelf between me and Tony is the
trouble with academia so I think it
would be naive to say everything's fine
in academia and equally I think it would
it would be naive to say everything's
wrong with academia so the question is
which parts are worth salvaging we
parts need improvement and this is a big
theme of my book losing the Nobel Prize
I don't want to get rid of the Nobel
Prize I don't want to lose it completely
that the title is a double entendre yeah
but instead I want to reform it and use
its current stature to protect it
against assaults from outside and inside
and so far they haven't really listened
to me but but the question is maybe or
not maybe we can get some traction if we
bring in outsiders and that's the only
way to make chat and make change right
Tony if I say you can't criticize the
president Tony because you're not the
president well that's a stupid argument
I'm of course we anything criticize
anyone we want that's right and I think
to invalidate his opinion because he
doesn't want to subscribe to the classic
journal publication referee narrative
there's some validity to that and and in
the interview with him I kind of
challenged him here and there and the
most fun part maybe we'll get to is his
concept what should an academic
establishment look like how should
academia look and what would he do
differently what would he teach what
would he do without and those were
fascinating things to hear him discuss
and it was sort of a pre father's
original I was gonna have just Eric be
my father's Day guest I had Sascha Segan
you remember I had Sasha we still
haven't talked about Sascha Segan in
between me interviewing her for my
Mother's Day podcast on the into the
impossible podcast I had I had her
mother Anne jury and on and she was a
delight and I've had on Asha you know
I'm so backed up tawny and and I have so
much awesome content one request for
folks out there iTunes is this
mysterious force on on YouTube we can
look up how many views there's 10,000
people watching you know every one most
every one of Tony's videos I get about
1% of that but you know I can hope and
but on iTunes they track reviews and
ratings of the podcast so I'm gonna put
a link to to the website you can
download if you're on an iPhone or
whatever right now I think you can go to
it even if you're not but please go to
this site and leave a review leave a
review an array because that's how Apple
determines whether or not I could I
should get advertising on their platform
and you know the hardest thing is
getting the word out
right and sorry Tony to blabber on so
long but no this is great I this is why
we're here we're here to promote what
you're doing and to get the word out so
keep blabbing man I just wanted I just
want to point out though iTunes is okay
I mean iTunes it is what it is if you've
got a if you've got the Apple ecosystem
on you and then it's a great way to
listen to podcast but do you you do so
you do syndicate to Spotify right and to
other places right I actually don't know
you know I have so much other stuff
going on my life with my alright well
let me just school you in something real
quick yeah you need to get on anchor dot
F M okay an anchor dot FM is owned by
Spotify and it will syndicate one of the
reasons you want to be on it is it will
automatically put you on every platform
out there including Spotify including
stitcher all these other things where
podcasts are set stitcher is big for
cars cars apparently have this built
into their operating system so you want
this is another way to get the word out
so I put both of my podcasts on anchor
dot FM and then it syndicates it for me
it's free and I can also monetize it so
it's not like SoundCloud where
eventually you've got a pay money or you
know to get any kind of plays out of it
and it'll put it on iTunes if you're
already there so it won't do it but it
would if you weren't so just look into
that anchored at a time get you on all
the platforms besides besides iTunes but
yes you're right still go and do a
review yeah please do that so thank you
Tony I appreciate everything that you do
and not just for me personally but you
do so much for the community of
astronomy and you provide a wonderful
forum I I just can't say enough I'm a
big supporter you know I've been a
supporter even longer than I've been a
guest but the reason I brought up Eric
and this Mother's Day Father's Day thing
is that in between having Eric on back
in May remember this is part two of our
interview so check out part one after
we're done chatting today but I did an
interview with none other than Jim
Simons and it's actually his first ever
podcast I believe that he's ever done
he's a reclusive you know in some sense
billionaire who's really revolutionized
transformed for the better basic science
so he and the Simons Foundation support
basic research they're not trying to
target
you know cures for cancer or something
like that that has admirable as that is
or malaria like the Gates Foundation and
those are certainly admirable but he's
only focused on math and computing and
fundamental physics and that includes my
Simons Observatory project that I
co-lead with three other of the most
brilliant professors astronomers in the
world mark Devlin Suzanne Staggs Adrian
Lee are the spokespersons on the
director of the project office here in
San Diego and we run this observatory
and it wouldn't have happened without
Jim Simons so I had the honor of
interviewing him which I'm gonna air her
this Sunday on his first ever podcast
I'm quite proud of it
awesome well congratulations I'm glad
you got that so what is the call to get
me back to this to this would you call
it this this WWF thing this total
fighting championship thing what what's
the I mean how do we support this
because I want to see Sean Carroll and
all these other guys but mostly Sean
Carroll in an inner ring doing what with
the debate I want to see this so is this
a special webinar event you're planning
or what yeah the tentative idea is to
partner with a very well-known YouTube
channel which I'm not gonna mention just
yet because we this is a channel has
millions of subscribers and that does
phenomenal work across all science but
in particular has a deep interest in in
exploring the fundamental mysteries of
the standard model the theory of
everything and whether or not it exists
and we're gonna partner hopefully with
this channel and then our aim is to
attract almost you know like cinematic
quality webinar where we'd have you know
invitation and we'd have later
rebroadcast on YouTube and you and I
would certainly be involved in the
debrief of it as usual but this this
webinar would cover you know some of the
greatest people in science again no
one's agreed to this it's just kind of
my idea with with my friend and producer
here in San Diego along with this other
well-known YouTube channel we just
haven't inked out the final details and
it's not for profit we're not gonna make
any money off it but the idea is to get
the greatest so here's my dream team and
again no one said yes but it would be
Sean Carroll ed Witten the reputed to be
the smartest you
human being alive maybe least a Randal
who's one of the most brilliant people
taste her birthday today's her birthday
so send her some birthday wish though
yeah she's she's she's watching yeah I'm
sure she she's incredible should I look
up to her tremendously she's one of
these these people who rejected me to
give a blurb on losing the Nobel Prize
but I still love her anyway
she's too busy doing great stuff so Lisa
Randall
Sean Carol Stephon Alexander who I had
on my podcast Janna Levin who I had on
my podcast and then have these you know
Jim Gates who I've had in the podcast
have these intellects come together with
experimentalists and normally they'll
get together brian greene and they'll
they'll talk about these ideas and and
there's never really the kind of sober
experimentalist sitting there saying
what you're proposing you know for
example ed Witten has an idea and I
haven't looked at it in great depth yet
I want to invite him on my podcast to to
test to see if there's a planet 9 now
you and I grew up with nine planets so
if you had told us when we were in in
the 80s or whatever we were both kids
there's nine planets even you might
think that we could send a probe to
Pluto
like we did with deep horizons mm but a
new horizon but on the other hand it was
demoted right by Neil deGrasse Tyson
Mike Brown and others so it's not so now
they're all by the IAU they're just
taking credit for but but having a
planet 9 thanks Tom it's possibly a
black hole or some primordial other
other object that's not planetary in
nature so ed Witten has this idea that
you send this tiny spaceship out to
Planet 9 it takes a hundred years and
you measure as I understand again I've
only looked at this in the journal Club
no and then you measure a time delay
between radio waves sent between this
microscopic object and it will have a
different time delay if planet 9 is not
a planet but a black hole and that
differential time delay is like half a
millisecond or even less maybe and that
half a millisecond has to be measured
out of a hundred year long voyage
very speculative but but it will be
interesting to talk about this will we
ever make direct contact with the black
Hall I mean it would be startling if
there's a black Hall happens to be
orbiting you know Brian maybe more in
startling it be pants pooping scary okay
well it depends size of Pluto and it has
the gravitational force of Pluto or
something you know it's benign right so
it's not all black holes devour you for
dinner although my friend Janna Levin
whose episode will come out shortly her
next book and I'm gonna have her back on
it's called the black hole Survival
Guide so you know that could be couldn't
be more timely if it was about astronomy
you can use all right well glossy yeah
you're right there is a new study that
planet 9 might not even exist and there
were the observational biases on it
that's very true a lot of new
information coming out about this idea
so well yeah so I let me just offer you
words of encouragement to get this set
up I will participate and help in any
way that I can but let's okay let's get
to Eric for too much time goes by I
wanna I want to ask you about
well Galaxian wants to know about his
theory of what the theory of the
universe you know science instead of
sociology of science but also let's talk
a little bit about this this this
academia and problem problematic Ness it
was kind of embarrassing a little bit
because he he mentioned someone who's a
good friend of mine that he met this
person you know a few years back and
said you know do you know about when the
decline of academia started in America
and this person who's a high-ranking
academia and then he didn't understand
that according to Eric this really began
in the 1970s and Erika's very
controversial views about why this is
happening and and what the role the
National Science Foundation is what the
role of you know in his words you know
the kind of laves like tax on emails or
attacks on semiconductors because these
are all the output of physics that have
led to great industrial profits and
gains in the capitalist economy which we
know and love
most of us but and and because of that
he thinks that we're we're squandering
what is the sort of natural right
byproduct of our field and again mostly
he's advocating for theoretical physics
to be funded but but but the clear
message that he has is that academia it
has become incredibly siloed oh man ok I
starting to go back a little bit I'm
sorry but nobody was listening to any of
that ok I've got green on my stream
again I'm sorry I must be having up a
little issues it's just it's not
receiving enough video yeah it should be
fixed now ok refresh no you shouldn't
have to do anything just hunk it and
it'll it'll pick back up it was a
problem with my ISP ok ok all right can
you pick back up I'm really sorry I hate
so I was talking about you know kind of
the past history according to according
to Eric of you know what what actually
is the goal of a university and it's not
to make you know just these mono
you know focused individuals not that
it's you know not important to be the
world's expert in a given field of
academia but but that there should be
cross-pollination there should be in his
words physicists should know about the
worm you know C elegans and understand
it's it's connecthome and and that will
have surprising and I pointed out you
know rosalind Franklin who helped
identify the double helix structure of
DNA some say she was unfairly robbed I
do of the Nobel Prize in the 1960s both
for being a woman potentially but also
for being dead which i think is the
worst reason not to award in that one
prize but anyway we had this wonderful
you know kind of resonance at least on
that front where you know it takes multi
and interdisciplinary studies and that
you know a theorist like maybe Watson or
Couric or whoever could not have fully
understood it without an experimentalist
perspective and so I think he broadens
that to now say well all fields of you
know the hard sciences it's clear to me
that he doesn't have a great deal of
respect for the for the social sciences
etc and I'm not going to debate that
that's his opinion I believe they can
have value but but I can well you know
that's not an uncommon view among a lot
of a lot of scientists there's they
don't look at that as a science yeah so
it's applying scientific methods
methodology to something that they feel
is not fundamentally a scientific
endeavor but yeah yeah and so in in
terms of actually understanding what
what he would put at I created this
Weinstein University this fictitious
Weinstein University what would be
taught there and certainly you know he
believes that physics suffers from this
public relations nightmare which is that
we have the greatest content and we have
the worst marketers we have that what
most are you know brilliant talent so to
speak and we have the worst you know
possible showman so it gets left to a
handful of people who have an agenda and
that agenda is not too dissimilar get
this is don't kill the messenger this is
what he's saying no I'm with you I'm
actually with him on this keep going
yeah yeah so his their agenda is to
parrot back the scientific you know the
academia academic hierarchy that has put
in place according to him this
monolithic approach a string theory and
supersymmetry are really the most you
know promising paths even though we
don't see things directly in particle
physics that have any relation to
supersymmetry extra dimensions string
theory etc so he views this in Sabean
Hassan Felder who I had on last week as
well view this as a symptom a byproduct
of an of another type of bias and
prejudice and science so we're all
familiar with Authority bias Einstein
said this therefore you can't challenge
it even though every scientist says
there's no such thing as a god or a pope
or a bishop of science but it's not
really true if you if you remember your
physics classes in high school or even
in college they would say so-and-so did
this and then he won the Nobel Prize a
lot of times that's done and it rewrites
the way that history is perceived and I
know Eric agrees with me on that and so
because of that there is a hierarchy
whether or not we admit it there's an
authoritarian sort of discipline that
comes from the top right now the most
brilliant person alive according to many
people is Ed Witten and Ed Witten has
dedicated his life to understanding
things and the basic properties
of string theory so much so that he won
the he won the Fields Medal first
physicist to win the Fields Medal I
believe and that is given away you know
for his contributions which really in
the properties of extra these extra
dimensional representations called
groups that have applicability in string
theory and yet string theory itself
hasn't been verified so it's it's not
like Murray gell-mann who came up with
you know su 2 su 3 cross su 2 cross u 1
winning the Fields Medal for discovering
you know this group structure know it
that never happened and so so it's it's
curious to me and and I think ed is as
brilliant as anybody and and Eric
basically agrees that you know he is the
smartest human being on earth and yet
you know help hope put out things which
I view is completely impractical like
measuring to the microsecond spacecraft
traveling for a century you know doesn't
mean we shouldn't look at it analyze it
just means we shouldn't say everything
this person says cannot be challenged
and I think Eric is playing this role
he's not within the Academy he is
outside the Academy and that gives him
the ability to make a critique without
fear of repercussions and so I actually
asked him would you would Weinstein
University have tenure and guess what he
said no he said apps you're absolutely
wrong he said he said it whatever I had
a 50-50 chance denied some sweet odds
there Tommy he said it would it said it
would because it's absolutely essential
that you have this this academic freedom
and license to choose paths that may or
may not turn out to be correct and and
then I push back on him a little bit I
said look you know I don't know until
discovered a crisis he came about every
single one of my students this is my
biggest accomplishment my proudest
accomplishment as an academic I've never
shared this with with you but but it's
that every single one of my students
have have been fully employed now you
major Oh a big deal you know they know
it's incredibly important I've helped
men and women get jobs that paid for
their families that paid for their kids
and I played a role in that
I take great pride in a small
businessman running an operation that
has a multi-million dollar a year budget
that produces no widgets but still has
to come up and feed all these different
priorities that we have I take great
pride in that but I say every single one
of those until kovat and even with kovat
I think it's gonna be okay
but until kovat I had 14 graduate
students at a 16 graduate students that
got their PhD in the last 16 years in my
laboratory they all had not only full
employment most of them had multiple
offers you know how proud it's like I
don't know it makes me incredibly proud
and I love an advisor for sure Wow I
always say you know they say when a
student does poorly it reflects poorly
on the teacher and so I use the you know
the the contra position of that of that
argument I'm sorry I'd you're throwing
so much and I have to get a comment in
once in a while here because I got it
I'm gonna just latch on to what you just
said about how proud you are yeah about
of your own students being employed and
having multiple job offers and things
like this one of the problems in
academia in my opinion is that it there
is an unhealthy reliance on advisers if
you want to make it in the world so if
you're a graduate student and you are
trying to get a you want to become a
postdoc your success entirely depends on
the adviser that you have your students
are lucky because they have an advisor
who tries to keep them who engages them
who you looks at it you look at as your
responsibility to promote them their
work and get them started I can't tell
you how many advisors I've seen out
there who've let their students just
basically languish and I've used them
basically for slave labor and they were
you know they had to really fight to get
noticed in the field at all to me that
is one meant of the many problems of
academia what are your thoughts it's sad
and actually that's one very personal
grievance that Eric talks about publicly
in an interview he did with Lex Friedman
I can find that on Lex's channel and he
and I have talked about that offline
it's basically similar to what he and I
talked about I don't want to get into
that with with
on my podcast but I'll talk about it now
his he feels like he was unfairly denied
opportunities by by his it multiple he
didn't really have a single advisor at
Harvard so he could fault I was about to
say credit but it really blames Harvard
specifically for inculcating an
environment where they basically said
that you know he had to leave Harvard
and you know he had to go away and then
come back and and they didn't and they
did so in his opinion against all his
opinion to to maintain an almost cabal
like isolation of Eric and freethinkers
away from the orthodoxy that Harvard's
mathematics and mathematical physics
department theoretical physics group was
maintaining again I am NOT in that field
but this is his claim that he was
basically wronged by his advisors at
Harvard and he sees this throughout and
one of the clips that I'm gonna put on
my channel and a couple yeah yeah
without even knowing I did sounds like
something that would happen and he
actually cites Barack Obama whose father
went to Harvard and had a similar
experience where he had a like his
father he claims Eric says that that
Obama claims that his father he claimed
it was sent back to Africa to do some
stuff and wasn't allowed to like be
present at some part of his of his PhD
review now that that should be public
record I don't know anything about that
just one piece of evidence that Eric
broke so I started thinking like is this
a problem with Harvard you know a lot of
things happen at Harvard and it kind of
has looked at right as the gold standard
of of not just academia but of
intellectualism of thought and in
society and it has a tremendous
influence on on society and yet these
people they're at Lisa Randall I just
mentioned is a good friend of mine she's
there and you know she's had struggles
and challenges with their administration
as well she's in here she was the first
tenured professor at MIT
female tenured professor MIT in the
physics department she's an outstanding
scientist and yet she'll still have
troubles at these high levels of
academia and I asked Jim Simons I said
you know what were you like as a PhD
adviser you know he's the 36 richest
person in the world or something like
that and he and and he got there after
being an academic and that was really
his first career was after you know it
was running a large department this case
the math department at State University
of New York he did so and he shared with
me his ideas and had to do so but it
came down and the message I feel like
Eric missed is one of what I call love
and obviously it should be platonic but
I can't teach you something Tony if
you're scared of me if I say Tony asked
or intimidated by you yeah I have to
feel not love like you know it's just
there you know I think there's like 10
different words for love and Greek and
you know the only one of which is like
romantic but the others are like kinship
friendship camaraderie trust and and
they all go together Eric didn't find
that and he feels like that is the most
important thing you know one corollary
to what you said Tony a few minutes ago
which I wholeheartedly agree with about
academia and and how important an
adviser is there's a corollary which is
that it doesn't matter what you study it
almost doesn't matter what you study in
that if you have a good advisor and you
have a good relationship with with him
or her and he or she treats you with
love and kindness and respect and gives
you the freedom to explore and to think
for yourself you know but maintains a
certain number of guardrails just to
make sure you don't go off the cliff
then you can learn from anybody I truly
believe that I could have been a
different I could have been a different
physicist had my advisor but you know
studied a different thing when he was in
grad school in fact I thought I would be
doing something different when I was
under graduate when I went to graduate
school but it turned out it became a
cosmetologist and that's mainly based on
the strength of my my two advisors at
the time my PhD advisor Peter timbi at
University of Madison Wisconsin Madison
currently but he was back at Brown and
then my my father who also had a
tremendous influence on me to study you
know theoretical foundational aspects of
physics so you're right Eric's right but
the problem is we don't get any training
I never got training in what are the
basics of educational pedagogy that's
another problem with academia Brian is
that it doesn't value this this
relationship there's there's no there's
more than any other and were endeavour
for human beings
the the apprenticeship of becoming a
scientist is
among the most important and yet a
university we'll look at at a faculty
member with two things in mind one the
the their fame or relative renown and
two the amount of money that they can
bring into their university everything
else is ancillary and and and and nice
to have if you're a good teacher oh
that's great but to me that should be
the number one thing because your
research is important
do your research but it should not Trump
everything else you should be able to in
fact you should value more the work
you're doing with your grad students in
fact you should be you shouldn't I just
had this idea maybe it exists but you
should be held responsible for and given
and what's the word I'm looking for
given credit for based on the work your
students do if your students are doing
great work then that reflects on you
positively in the university if you're
getting papers published if you're
bringing in if you're if you have the
potential to bring in money or whatever
that should they should the focus should
be on the student in that in that case
yeah I agree
this quote that I heard once from the
famous physicist nobel prize winner
Isidore isaac rabbi or rabbi robbie and
he said something to the effect like as
a scientist a professor you are paid to
do research and and and make money
basically or you know get grants but if
you're a gentleman you also teach and I
was thinking like what if you're a
parent like you know again Father's Day
is coming up and we both have a bunch of
kids between us and and I wonder you
know like what if that was our you know
responsibility like if you're a
gentleman you also love your kids
oh it's it should be number one and in
fact you know I brought this up with I
think I was talking to I was talking to
Adam riess actually I had him on the
podcast again I've got this huge backlog
I'd love to know how you deal with these
backlogs of these wonderful guests that
you get on the show without pissing them
off because it's like I you know I want
to release it I know the people out
there gonna love these these interviews
with Adam riess Nobel Prize winner you
know and I was talking to him and I was
like you know you value yourself as a
teacher but we were never taught on how
to teach and I said you know the
one place I learned how to be a teacher
and that's the last place you would
expect it and he said no and I said the
federal government he's like what are
you talking about I said well one of my
you know aspirations is to use my
pilot's license to someday become a
commercial flight instructor and to
become a commercial flight instructor
you have to be familiar with what's
known as Maslow's hierarchy of needs and
it's the only document in the whole
Federal Register I mean try to go to the
IRS or the you know the Federal
Communications Commission and find a
pyramid you know that shows what needs a
human being has in order to feel loved
and safe and taking it it's like love is
one of the needs that Maslow identified
like imagine that in the IRS anyway why
is it in the FAA handbook well because
if a student feels fear for his or her
safety
they're not gonna absorb anything if
someone you know feels like their
physiological needs are not met they're
not gonna be able to process things and
they're in flight instruction what are
the consequences mean they don't just
mean you lose a Nobel Prize they mean
you die and you maybe kill a lot of
other people so if it's important and
good enough for the federal government
it should at least be important enough
and good enough for UC San Diego and
Harvard and other places so we don't
teach teachers what students need to be
students I'm hoping to change that
someday and and I'd love to get feedback
from people on what kinds of people make
for good teachers and and there's a
wonderful lecture by Bill Gates or
there's an essay by Bill Gates called
the best teacher I never had and it's
about Fineman and of course finally was
no flawless individual nobody is but but
he was known for his pedagogical skills
and and yet he didn't have that many PhD
adviser I have twice as many as he ever
had and so it's and again the quantities
not that important but but the quality
should be so I guess wrapping it up in
terms of this little segue in academia
and Eric Weinstein I didn't feel like he
has a point
if he was truly excluded and I only have
his word to take from it and you should
look up that interview with Lex Friedman
and maybe someone can put in the
comments but he talked about Harvard and
and just these this off quite frankly I
think it was traumatic for him and you
know he's just huge you know burly but
you know a guy that's just so tough and
intellectually tough but I saw a
vulnerability and I heard that in his
words
and it made me think you know the guy is
some very provocative things about
science but also about the process of
science in academia
yeah and it's at its core science is a
human endeavor and from that point all
problems and good things arise from it
and the practice of it and the practice
of being involved in science is based on
our humanity and it comes with all the
others the inherent problems or issues
that are come with that so I don't have
a lot of time with you I want to ask
Alexia's question but before I do that I
have a question and that is you you know
it's funny to me you're taught you said
many times already that Ed Witten is or
is one of the most considered the most
smartest person in the world I've never
heard that but I'll take your word for
it also Eric Weinstein is obviously very
smart as well and yet they have a
problem with social social sciences be
considered a science and yet they will
devote their lives to something like
string theory and these these theories
that have no hope of getting verified in
the scientific using the scientific
tools were used to engaging in how do
they reconcile that I mean it seems to
me like to me string theory is
borderline pseudoscience because yet all
you can say about it is the Mantha's
great and this is cosmic landscape from
Leonard Susskind and all of these other
you know people are engaging in
something I'm gonna question is actually
science because how can we ever verify
any of this and all you can say is it's
the math the math works out well then
that means that math must equal reality
if you're going to accept this as a
science so what do you think they would
have to say about that comment that I
just made that if this stuff isn't
science well I think that you know there
is a sense that that science is depends
on what can be falsified you and I have
talked about that I've talked about that
was to be in Holland Felder I actually
don't subscribe to that I think that
that's a limitation only one part of it
there's it's not like we don't have the
technology to do it and maybe one day
we'll discover gravitational waves like
with Einstein's relativity it's that we
cannot fundamentally ever hope to follow
any of this stuff up with observations
of any kind that we can bring into this
universe this will always be outside of
our experience I don't agree with that I
mean again technology well I think that
there are things again I don't agree
that falsification is the sin akwonton
agreed agreed I don't that's not the
only thing that makes something science
why would you I mean again if I asked
you in 1979 would we detect
gravitational waves from from black
holes or the big bang uses but that has
always been theoretically possible right
this other stuff is theoretically
impossible we cannot measure anything
shorter than the Planck length our laws
of physics already tell us that and yet
these strings are much much far smaller
than that and they have dimensions on an
order of depending on who you talk to 11
to $10,000 a hominid but it's a
ridiculous number of dimensions that
we're never going to be able to interact
with it's not like so we don't have the
technology now and if we just wait a bit
we'll be able to detect it later it's
not like that it's like we're never
gonna be able to many-worlds quantum
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics never gonna be able to verify
that well according to Shawn if you
listen to my interview with him back in
December on my channel I'll put a link
to it he believes you can test it he
actually proposed a way to test the the
existence of the many worlds hypothesis
I personally wasn't you know a swayed to
to a great extent to reorient my lab to
do this I think it had to do with
certain types of Bell Nani nonlocality
test and delayed choice tests and things
like that
he claims it's you know it's not far
away from being possible
again I'm not reorienting my lab from
cosmology to testing many worlds
interpretation so there I'd say he would
disagree with you on string theory you
may be right into what's called a direct
detection but but in terms of Duren
direct detection 'he's there are many
you know plausible at least hopes to do
this otherwise you know we wouldn't been
looking for for after
at least say supersymmetry we wouldn't
been looking for that look just because
we can't see a quark with a microscope
doesn't mean that we can't see its
effects indirectly like we've never
directly seen a gluon but we have
evidence for it indirectly and then the
doctor yeah the same way although with
this week tomorrow stay tuned for an
interview so tomorrow on my podcast
this is controversies week so I had Eric
on this week he's super controversial
the least controversial guy I had on was
chase Purdy who wrote a book about
laboratory-grown meat which is really
exciting to those of us who want to
reduce the amount of meat that we eat
and so this is taking stem cells
culturing them growing a hamburger in
the in the lab it's called
billion-dollar burger for how much these
things used to cost literally and now
they're down to about 500 dollars I'm
still not going out to buy a you know
platter of these for my kids on Father's
Day but so he was the least
controversial guy check his interview
out it was great but then I'm having
tomorrow I'm having on Christopher con
Solis who is one of the co-authors of
this study that claims there's 36
extraterrestrial civilizations in the
universe have you heard that study yeah
that was big news this week yeah he's
coming on tomorrow and then after him
Chi Chuan knee professor colleague of
mine here at UC San Diego is a leader on
the Xenon one ton experiment that just
had results pertinent to dark matter
just yesterday so tune in tomorrow I try
to just do no processing they're gonna
do a slideshow presentation send me
questions you know go on Twitter send me
questions for those guys out there I
always love getting I know Peters a huge
huge fan and and sends always these
great question so I'm gonna put my link
to Twitter so ask questions of me there
that you want me to ask either about the
Xenon experiment and then Tony you and I
still have to talk about the Anita
experiment and that's gonna bring us
full circle as we close out because Eric
claims in geometric unity that it's
possible that one could detect
signatures of these 14 dimensional
spaces that he conjectures but using the
properties of these strange particles
that seem to be emanating from from the
from the from Antarctica that are
detected by Anita that have been used to
claim evidence in other cases of a power
so that was about three weeks ago
controversial up post in the New York
Post and now we've got this you know
I've got this incredible reputation on
my channel by a BB reg who's a professor
at University cago and she is one of the
people that is responsible for the
actual experiment that she claims was
taking completely out of context so it's
really hard to be an experimentalist cuz
everyone puts this pressure on us
there's not that much new data that
comes in physicists scrutinized over
anything that literally is a one or two
Sigma or 3 Sigma bump like this Zenon
experiment so I'm gonna ask that about
that tomorrow to my colleague on the
Xenon experiment but it's a data star
field so what do you do when that
happens you either make up things that
can't be tested or you can or you can
actually you know try to think about
experiments but look how expensive these
experiments are the Simon's Observatory
is a hundred million dollar project we
won't be on the air for another three
years and it'll take five years to be
completed it's not a game for people
that are impatient so we tend to recycle
stuff in the past but I'm interested to
hear how we could test things both using
cosmology both using accelerator
experiments and perhaps using new what's
called phenomenology if we do go ahead
and do this webinar about the theory of
everything and one of the questions I'm
gonna ask is who needs a theory of
everything in honor of my good friend
Tony Darnell wow thanks man
tropical tom thank you very much for
supporting the channel I do appreciate
it I got a couple questions here that
one okay well actually wants to know if
you read Li smullins book the trouble
with physics yeah I read I got about
halfway through that it was he was my
first kind of you know foray into
controversies in physics his was
actually that book galaxia was actually
the first book I ever downloaded on a
Kindle when he came to visit me in San
Diego about 12 years ago and I actually
asked him to sign my Kindle I can't find
where it is because it's really old but
anyway Lee's coming on my show this
summer talked about his new book
Einstein's unfinished revolution I think
that's the title of it and then he had
another book about time that came out
and and he's just such a fascinating
intellect and he's what we call a mensch
he's one of the sweetest guys but he he
did an interview with Lex Friedman and
you should check that out too so Lex is
copying me up for a lot of these guests
oh stop it Lex
he's never gonna get Jim Simons or you
know he may get Eric Eric Weinstein and
other people I don't think he's gonna
get Jim Simons
Never Say Never but but Galaxia getting
back to him he claims that this that
there is no scientific method and I'm
gonna talk to him a lot about that
because he would disagree
not only with popper as Tony and I do
but he would disagree with the notion
there even is a scientific method and I
think that's just a fast a such a
brilliant mind well yeah I mean it's in
and I might even find myself agreeing
depending on the words he uses because
it's you know it's it's interested to
the degree that we have a method it's
certainly imperfect and it's full of
issues up among them these problems were
having an academia that's probably our
problem with science in general as well
so I don't think already has to say what
another question according or words are
gonna ask you uh
Oh Peter wants to know why don't you ask
why don't I ask Brian if Weinstein is
planning on publishing yeah so again
this is this is one reason to join my
mailing list because he is not planning
on publishing anytime soon
unlike wolfram he has he has no plans to
publish his new theories of fundamental
theories of everything but what I did do
is I got him to agree to let me take his
PowerPoint slides from his Oxford
lecture in 2013 I converted them into a
PDF and when you guys join my mailing
list you know I will send you a link to
download the the slides and you could
peruse them and then watching them along
with the videos that he and I have done
and he's done by himself including his
famous April Fool's Day April first
episode where he goes through the slides
himself you can go through them at your
leisure I'm encouraging him to write a
book in all seriousness he at the end of
this conversation from this week so
again check out the interview I did with
Eric part two on this on this week's
caste and and I'll put the link here and
it's also in the description box of this
video so I asked him I said are you
gonna write a book not just for your own
not just for your own you know theory of
geometric unity but also about you know
kind of like your legacy and and how you
know you want to leave in the spirit of
what I thought would be my Father's Day
episode advice to your kids to the to
the world about what means most and what
matters most to you what I what I'm
calling an ethical will I ask all my
guests what kind of wisdom and not
monetary wealth do you want to leave to
the future what intellectual wisdom do
you want to leave and so anyway sign up
for the mailing list you know Eric's got
his podcast called the portal apparently
mine is gonna be called the funnel
because I want to get you guys all
signed up my email list so that I can
keep in touch with you because we we
have a lot more content coming out on
the channel and and I want to share it
with everybody because it takes a lot of
time to do it and it's so much fun I
want to share it with as many people as
I can so we send out show notes and
sometimes exercises for the reader so I
have one with a workbook that actually
is in Python and it actually allows
people to look at and also an animation
of what's called the hopf fibration
which is Eric's favorite intellectual
you know windmill to tilt ahead so take
a look sign up for the mailing list I'll
shoot you guys a copy of the slides as
well as some fun other resources that
I'm putting together yeah man I mean
it's like Brian Penley is commenting all
this cool science stuff almost feels
like a potential scientific Renaissance
law let me just say you know Brian what
you're doing with these interviews is
astonishing you're getting all of the
people I think worth listening to and in
one in one place and you're in your
cataloging some great conversations I
can't believe the people you're getting
and so this is like you know I've always
fancied myself you know somewhat of an
interviewer but nothing like this
because it's you know the people that
you're talking to her all my almost all
of them are my heroes or somebody who's
super famous and I would love to talk to
anyway so excellent work
definitely subscribed to his
list as well let me just get two big new
games question he goes I think that a
lot I thought that LIGO gravitational
waves would have shown multiple
universes yeah I didn't hear that I did
you know I know that's not something I
would either expect or have heard about
from from LIGO it's not something I
think that they have access to what they
do have access to is a way to test the
Hubble constant to look for this Hubble
tension that you and I first talked
about back in January I think Tony and I
talked about that with Adam riess and I
asked him what do you think is the most
likely resolution of the Hubble tension
problem that was one question another
question is how do you propose that we
can you know better get at data to
resolve it with higher precision in the
future that was number two and then I
asked him how did you spend your Nobel
Prize winnings and you'll tune in
whenever whenever I actually get around
to posting it it should be soon yeah
he's a really funny guy I have to share
one thing from Adam Rees that he shared
with me you know saying look you know
the the Nobel Prize is so highly
esteemed by the public I get and I'm
sure you get countless emails per week
let's say you know professor Reiss or my
you know Brian key professor Keating
I've got this incredible idea for
parallel universe detection with LIGO or
whatever not saying it's a bad idea but
if you help me with the math and help me
get it published I'll share the Nobel
Prize with you Adam said that's how I
won my Nobel Prize I sign off I want to
wish everybody a great Father's Day to
all the fathers or father figures out
there it's more important than ever
we had a very stressful week you know
with the shutdown of academia shut down
stem really evaluating what sorts of
problems we might be facing in academia
and I'm proud to say that my team on the
Simons Observatory and I have created a
new partnership with the National
Society of black physicists of which I'm
an honorary lifetime member if
can believe that that we're going to
establish a program for members of the
NS VP to receive summer internships that
are paid quite handsomely with the
Simons Observatory working over the
summer this year so NS BP members can
apply for it and go to my our website
Simon's Observatory org and become a
part of it and we're looking to expand
it and the last thing I'll say is next
Wednesday at 11:00 a.m. Pacific I
believe is a webinar by the APS about
diversity inclusion efforts led by my
really close friend and mentor Jim Gates
and he's the incoming president of the
American Physical Society in the past
president of the National Society of
black physicists he's gonna have a lot
to say I might pipe up on the on the
webinar to discuss the program that I
just mentioned through the Simons
Observatory so with that Tony I really
appreciate you appreciate all my all the
listeners out there please go to the
iTunes and rate and review the podcast
so we can continue attract you know
podcasting is all about getting getting
good guess based on other good guests so
I've had on four Nobel Prize winners a
Pulitzer Prize winner many great authors
and thinkers so help help keep that
going by by getting the ratings and
reviews and I would really be a
wonderful gift to me for Father's Day
okay Brian
well we'll do that I need to go back and
relist into the Sean Carroll one because
I think I've missed that part where he
said it could be both verified so I'm
gonna have to go back and read that
there's all that again
so yes thank you dr. point you guys get
you can head out if you need to go I
understand I'm going to read a couple of
comments before I sign off because
there's some some questions in here and
I want to make sure I get to them so
okay all right by the way Susan I just
want to thank you also for the for your
support that was all these are I this is
amazing it's like you guys are like
chipping in here and there this is this
hapless happens you know more more
frequently now makes me very very
excited and it really helps because
YouTube is a very problematic YouTube
platform for me to earn any money on
almost everything I post now gets D
monetized for for Content ID problems
that
are legitimate and so so this kind of
support I think I get to keep so it goes
to me and thank you very much for all of
the people who have done that it really
does help deep astronomy keep going
because like I said I don't you you
think that with the millions of uses
whom my videos have had I'd be raking in
the money but I don't make any money on
any videos now so it's they've all with
the exception of the Hubble Deep Field
in 3d that's the only video I have
that's in the millions of views that is
actually earning money all the rest some
of them have been be monetized because
of Content ID problems so thank you for
your support is what I'm trying to say
there are you still here are you still
here Brian I thought you left
oh you're oh ok sorry I thought you were
gone already yeah you want to look give
the link to the Sean Carroll buddy
take care let's talk next week all right
yep see you next week all right take
care bye bye
all right there we go
so sorry about that I didn't know he was
still there I would have had him ask a
couple more questions big new games like
oh then confirmed that multiple universe
or parallel universes did not exist
because there was no delay in the
signals okay but I